and finally new rule democracy isn't a
spectator sport and if trump's going to
try to scuttle the post office
we need to fight back now i must admit
of the ways
i'd always imagined donald trump would
try to steal the election
[ __ ] with the mail never occurred to
me
but i didn't think he could take the
money congress gave the pentagon and
redirected to the wall
and he did that i sure wasted a lot of
time in civicus class with those note
cards
since april the president has launched a
two-front campaign against the postal
service first
undermining trust in mail-in voting by
calling it corrupt
so later he can challenge any results he
doesn't like
and then by undermining the postal
service itself
eliminating overtime firing leadership
reducing sorting machines
so that when the surge of mail-in ballot
starts coming in in october
the post office will be too gutted and
strapped to handle it and ballots won't
get counted
he wants it to fail it has to fail for
his scheme to work
it's like a postal version of the
producers
and there's all sorts of anecdotal
evidence now that the system
is starting to crack people not getting
their mail
getting it very late last week i got an
issue of rolling stone with bob seger on
the cover
there's a never-ending well of
creativity on the right
to keep people from voting and this is
the latest dirty trick
but maybe there is something we can do
to fight back
if trump is going to reduce mail
processors
it isn't our power to give them less
mail to process
yeah in-person absentee voting begins in
two weeks on september 14th in
pennsylvania two weeks
so i say you have two weeks to use the
postal service or everything you
normally do
and after that hashtag free up the mail
other than essentials like receiving
paychecks prescription drugs
and of course the victoria's secret
catalog
don't use the mail for anything but
ballots until the election is over
you know how we pull over for fire
trucks it's time we do the equivalent
for mail trucks let this be our october
surprise for trump
so that means get all your amazon crap
now
all the [ __ ] you don't really need
candles and [ __ ]
driftwood art and elbow moisturizer get
it all out of your system now
and then lay off the add to cart button
for a month
same thing with the rest of the mail
letters
i guess there's a certain charm to an
old school letter written out in cursive
but go back to charming after the
election it's not essential
the last person to send a letter that
mattered was the zodiac killer
dinner with the humorous yet vaguely
insulting birthday card
that you send to your aunt every october
getting older is like driving a classic
car the rear end sags and the fluids
leak
[Laughter]
yeah we'll say that over the phone this
year yeah call her up and say
aunt gertrude you are now like a car
your rear end sags and your fluids leak
i'm sorry you had to hear that over the
phone but i may have just saved
democracy
i'm sorry but we need to give our
besieged and intrepid postal workers the
time and space
they need to deliver nothing but balance
so fruit of the month club cancel it
wine of the month club get drunk on
something else
see monkeys ransom notes
no everything if you're still paying
your bills by mail
good time to join the new century no
save the date
cards no get well cards postcards
please please we have instagram now
you're embarrassing yourself
if you're still sending postcards it's
like watching a movie on netflix in 2020
and then trying to send it back
if you order your sex toys by mail sorry
get your ass out to the perv store and
buy your disgusting devices and
jellies in person and of course
what mostly would free up the mail would
be getting rid of this [ __ ]
capital one i don't know what your
politics are but somewhere in your evil
banker's hearts
you must think we should all at least
get the chance to vote
so next month don't send me an
application
you can throw it in the trash for me
all the businesses that fill up our
mailboxes every day
really take a little break bed bath
and beyond it's like a shark it has to
mail me a coupon every week or it dies
those postcards that look like they're
from someone you know but are just
real estate agents bragging hey i just
sold this [ __ ] box for 1.2
out letters with pennies taped to them
to guilt me into charity
the circular from the grocery store look
we have hot dogs
yeah we know ads for 99
lasik eye surgery if you only want 99
to fix my eyes i don't want you touching
my face
and here's something no one has ever
said hey gather around everyone the
latest penny saver is here
if the post office wasn't so overwhelmed
with the mountains of hot
garbage that flow through it every day
we might stand a chance of foiling the
fat man's plans
i don't want to lose this election
because of the mail
this is something we can do
you